is a Washington Middle School I have to
give a shout out to Ali London for for
finding this Middle School in Washington
that was holding a competition and it
was a competition not only between
students
and not only between staff members but
between students and staff members
sometimes competing against each other
and the competition was you would squirt
a little bit of whipped cream on a pane
of Glass on either side of a pane of
glass and you'd have one person on one
side and one person on the other and
then
they would lick the cream exactly
opposite one another
yeah
what
[Applause]
that stuff
[Music]
all right that's actually that's enough
I've seen I've I've never I hadn't
hadn't seen the video I just saw the
report on it and
had our editors pull the clip but that's
enough I think I get it how do you watch
that video how do you even hear about
this story and conclude that this isn't
a weird sex thing
for whoever thought it up
I I don't see how one I guess the silver
lining the storm cloud is glad to see
that covet is over in the schools glad
to see that now not only are we allowed
to meet with one another but we're
allowed to just lick panes of glass and
then swap out the students and the
teachers and then they lick all the same
panes of glass and I'm glad that that's
over but two
in in what world is this acceptable I'll
tell you the world that this is
acceptable and this is acceptable at a
weird party in college that's put on
probably in some frat house basement
where everyone is just kind of giggling
and they're all being a little bit
naughty and he he or you're going to
lick the whipped cream off the glass or
whatever okay that's where I would
expect to see a game like this
just a a more
licentious version of spin the bottle or
something okay
I that kind of a game makes sense to me
in that kind of environment I'm not
saying I'm encouraging it or anything
like that but I get it there
that kind of a game very much does not
make sense in a middle school
this is one of the more nuanced
conservative points on the whole drag
queen story hour discussion and debate
it's a point that Jonathan pegeot has
alluded to as well if you tell me that
we have a society in which in some dark
alley way in the bad part of town with
the red lights there's a cabaret that
puts on weird drag shows for guys who
show their ID and and pay some money to
get in and they're kind of embarrassed
by it but whatever it's some weird Quirk
that they have
I get that I'm not recommending that I'm
not saying that's a great thing that
Society should embrace but okay I get
that
but the moment that you take that Fringe
bizarre
shameful activity and you put that in
the very center of society you take it
away from that side street you put it in
the Public Square right in the middle
you put it on TV you put it in the
elementary school classroom then things
have gotten really strange
and and the way that Jonathan peggio
alludes to this
is is he says if you look at Medieval
manuscripts or if you look at Medieval
and Gothic Cathedrals you'll see
gargoyles and and all sorts of eccentric
things on the fringes on the outside in
the corners of the cathedral end of the
manuscript
elves with horns and weird sort of
genitals doing all sorts of silly
mischievous things
you'll see that on the on the fringes
well there are fringes to society
but when you put the things that are
supposed to be on the fringes at the
center of society then you invert your
standards then Society gets to be really
really weird
I would recommend
that the school investigate whoever came
up with this idea because while it might
seem like weird
basically innocent kind of fun to some
people whoever proposed and permitted
this kind of a game to go on is
definitely a creep there's just no way
about it right now go to cinch.com use
promo code Knowles the weather is
warming up over here in Nashville do you
know what that means it's grilling
season time to take that Grill pill baby
and I could not be more excited about
backyard Gatherings this summer but the
last thing you're going to want to do
when you've got all your friends coming
over for a barbecue is drive around
worrying about where to refill the
propane tank that is where cinch comes
in clutch cinch is a propane grill tank
delivery service they deliver propane
tanks right to your door cinch delivers
on your schedule and requires no
long-term commitment or subscription
plus delivery is completely contactless
you don't have to wait around at home
track the order on the Cinch app from
anywhere whether you're grilling for the
game camping with your family or
lighting up your patio heaters on a cold
night cinches propane delivery service
ensures you have the fuel you need to
make the most of every moment go online
to cinch.com download their app to order
new customers can get their first tank
exchange for just ten dollars with promo
code Knolls go to cinch.com or download
the Cinch app use promo code Knowles to
get your first tank exchange for just 10
bucks
cynch.com promo code Knowles this is a
limited time offer you must live within
a cinched service area to redeem it
cinch.com offer for details now getting
back to 2024 and the DeSantis of all of
it all for a second
I just would like to establish at the
outset I've said from the beginning I do
not
as a rule make endorsements in primary
campaigns I don't think that's my job
and in especially in 2024
I think we're in Uncharted Territory in
terms of a defeated Republican well
a reportedly defeated Republican
president who is then running for
re-election and you've got a strong
Republican governor coming there but
you've got a big split in the GOP
between the old kind of liberal way of
doing things the squishy way of doing
things and this new Insurgent muscular
assertive more nationally focused more
populist more virtue-minded rather than
libertarian-minded kind of conservatism
and so
I I think we ought to let the thing play
out I love Donald Trump he's the best
president of my lifetime I just think
he's terrific and I think he offered a
real alternative to a lot of the squishy
Republican policies
of the past because of the Trump
movement you saw Governors like Rhonda
Santos come up and Ronda Santos has done
a terrific job in Florida so Ron
DeSantis now is making the argument I'm
younger I'm I'm I get what's going on
here I don't have the baggage that Trump
does so he's making his play and they're
they're both making the play for the
same kind of campaign then there are a
lot of other people running for
president as well so I'm just putting
this out at the front I know there are a
lot of pundits who say I'm only for
DeSantis I'm totally on the DeSantis
train or they'll say DeSantis is a total
establishment squish hack neocon or
whatever things are saying because
they're on the Trump train
and here I am here I am the the lone
Republican saying this is a primary
let's recognize that Trump's the best
president in our lifetimes it's
recognized that DeSantis has done a
great job as Governor let's recognize
these are big boys they got thick skin
they know how to make it through an
election they can run for an office
we'll let the process play out
so one of the people who's now coming
out in favor of DeSantis as the
politicians are going to do now you're
going to increasingly see more and more
endorsements among the electeds is Chip
Roy who's great member of Congress uh
former Chief of Staff to Ted Cruz I'm
pretty sure he was Ted's Chief of Staff
now a member of Congress in his own
right and he says
I love Trump but I'm endorsing to Santos
like I was a strong supporter of Senator
Ted Cruz in 2016 in the primary yeah got
behind president Trump uh once we uh
chose him as the nominee on May 3rd of
that year I remember it well this time
I'm supporting Rhonda Stanis I'll
support the Republican nominee no matter
what I'm a strong supporter of the
America First agenda but look I I put
out in my statement I think it's time to
have someone who's not a baby boomer
somebody who can serve for two terms
that we know we can get behind to root
out all the corruption in this town and
beat the swamp that President Trump so
ably started when he came in in 2016.
and look Governor DeSantis has an
enormously successful record and he just
won re-election by a million and a half
votes he won 62 percent of Hispanic
voters 50 50 percent of single females
they have massive job growth great
economy he's taken on the education
establishment he's taken on the
corporate establishment with Disney and
so I just think it's time we have
someone that we can take a new
generation into town and we can kind of
to build on what president Trump started
and Governor DeSantis is a great guy to
get behind to do that
okay very well articulated endorsement
what's interesting to me is not that he
picked DeSantis over Trump or anything
like that what's most interesting to me
is how temperate this endorsement was
how polite this endorsement was
and I think you're going to see a lot of
these kinds of endorsements especially
from the serious people which is
I love Trump but I think DeSantis is
better for the moment or contrary to
that I've Loved a scientist he's a good
Governor but I think Trump is better for
the moment
that and there are other candidates as
well our friend Larry Elder just
announced that he's going to run for
president obviously we've had the bake
on the show before we've had Nikki Haley
on the show before there are other
people who are who are running and they
very possibly will have moments in the
race and who knows they could maybe take
the whole thing
all the Republicans now that I talk to
they're a little bit upset because they
say ah I just wish DeSantis would wait
his turn
oh now it's going to be a mean primary
or a contrary to say I just oh I wish
Trump would get out of the way oh and
just give it to DeSantis
when you've got endorsements that say I
love this guy but I'm giving this other
one the slight Edge
that's a good problem to have it's a
good problem to have that we have strong
GOP candidates who are moving the party
in the right direction on policy can we
be happy with that conservatives we
always want to be so doer you know we
always want to say oh the world is
ending it's all it's all over we've lost
everything our problem right now in 2024
is that we've got two candidates who are
too good who we like too much
and more than that actually because as
you know I think I'm going to try to
interview all of the all of the
Republican candidates we've got more
than that DeSantis and Trump are the two
Far and Away at the top of the polls
right now but we've got lots of
candidates who are great I'm looking
down at my iPad with the member chat
people love the bake people love people
are saying oh Larry Elder just announced
there's a lot of great candidates
take the win guys let the process play
out see who's the toughest one see who's
the best one then we go on and we try to
undo the rigging of Elections by the
Democrats and we try to own the libs
sounds sounds like a plan to me man how
insightful was that that was a great
clip you can get more Great Clips you
can get the whole show by subscribing
ring that Bell click that button do that
thing and subscribe to the Michael
nolsher YouTube channel see you next
time
[Music]
foreign